[Music]
rough times for Mitt Romney have you
heard this Thanks
no apparently they've been writing about
this since losing the election Mitt
Romney is reportedly bored
yeah after hearing this Ann Romney said
you're bored I'm sitting around all day
with Mitt Romney that's the problem
former Vice President Dick Cheney is
writing a book about his health problems
yeah the the book is called life of too
much pie
sorry I'm sorry that's just awful
that's awful that should never have
happened a lot of dissension among
conservatives one of the leaders of the
Tea Party has resigned after a major
split in the movement yeah the Tea Party
is now divided between angry whites and
even angrier whites that's a problem
we've got to get them together right
gonna bring this country together Kate
Middleton having a baby and then
exciting
whoo not our country new mom Snooki new
mom Snookie Snookie says she wants to
give baby advice to Kate Middleton
Snookie said her number one tip is find
out who the father is
any Star Wars fans here some of those
noises don't match up with Star Wars
hero by Star Wars 9 or something no good
news for Star Wars fans
federal officials announced they will
allow Disney to purchase George Lucas
George Lucas's company they will allow
that to go through the officials were
initially worried it would create a
monopoly but then obi-wan waved his hand
in front of them suddenly it was cool
[Applause]
it's not a monopoly it's not a monopoly
no reason to act that out
hey Kim Kardashian's in the news Kim
Kardashian's been touring the Middle
East touching off angry protests among
conservative Muslims yeah yeah it's
funny you've been conservative Muslims
would be happy to see a woman who's
never had a job it's not what they're
all about
that lines up nicely yeah check this out
in Russia there was a 125 mile traffic
jam that had drivers stuck in traffic
for over three days yeah here in Los
Angeles that's known as Friday Chris
Brown in the news Chris Brown was
photographed in Amsterdam with three
joints in his mouth
Brown was so high he almost punched a
man
went on the CEO of the Olive Garden
blames his company's low profits on
Obamacare which is not because most
people won't eat at the Olive Garden
until they have health insurance I
thought about that story thank you the
IRS very very gentle exchange here joke
and they flap and they're like would
like to hear another that was good now I
think one more I think we're done but
thank hey gang check this out
the IRS seized Lindsay Lohan's bank
account because she owes two hundred and
thirty three thousand dollars in back
taxes yeah Caesar bank account yeah they
were going to take her car too but they
couldn't get it out of the tree
[Applause]